[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Donnerstagabend im zweiten deutschen
Fernsehen und hier ist unser Thema
Frieden für die Ukraine das wollen alle
aber wie auf der einen Demonstration
würden mehr Waffen gefordert auf der
anderen weniger verhandeln jetzt sagen
die einen verhandeln mit wem und worüber
das Fragen die anderen wann wird es
soweit sein kann man diesen Moment auch
verpassen würde Vermittlung helfen und
selbst wenn dieser Krieg endet wäre
damit schon ein stabiler Frieden
erreicht fragen über Fragen an diese
Gäste
Saskia esken die Parteivorsitzende der
SPD
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken
Amira Mohammed Ali
die deutsch-ukrainerin Marina weiß waren
die konfliktforscherin Nicole deitelhoff
und der ehemalige Diplomat Wolfgang
Ischinger
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
[Musik]
und die begrüßt alle gestern noch mal
ausgesprochen herzlich je länger der
kriegt dauert liebe Zuschauer desto
lauter wird nach Verhandlungen gerufen
[Musik]
wer darf sich Lennons friedenshymne
aneignen
sind es die die fordern Frieden schaffen
ohne Waffen die Diplomatie und
Verhandlungen statt deutscher
Panzerhaubitzen und Leoparden
wir fühlen uns auch nicht vertreten von
einem Kanzler der zwar zunächst immer
zögert und für Bedachtsamkeit und
Vorsicht wirbt aber dann trotzdem
regelmäßig vor den kriegstrommlern in
seiner Koalition einknickt
dass man sich für Frieden rechtfertigen
muss oder sind es jene die die Ukraine
ausdrücklich auch mit Waffen
unterstützen wollen
wenn man sich jetzt unterwirft dann wird
es noch schlimmer für die Ukraine auf
jeden Fall
[Musik]
die Antwort ist kompliziert
ja die beiden wollten damals Frieden
schaffen ohne Waffen waren aber auch
überzeugt dass die Amerikaner Vietnam
verlassen soll
und heute
überwältigende Unterstützung für die
Ukraine und erhebliche Zweifel am Weg
58 Prozent der Deutschen fordern mehr
Diplomatie nur ein Drittel findet die
Bemühungen ausreichend
[Musik]
bei uns ist eine der zwei
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Linken formur
mit Ali sie waren am Samstag bei der
Demonstration mit dabei und haben auch
dass Manifest von Sahra Wagenknecht mit
unterschrieben warum haben Sie das
gemacht und warum haben sich die beiden
Parteivorsitzenden der Linken anders
entschieden glauben sich ich habe das
immer nicht fest unterschrieben weil ich
das inhaltlich richtig finde ich finde
wirklich dass Deutschland jetzt viel
stärker diplomatien in den Vordergrund
stellen muss und ich bin nicht davon
überzeugt dass immer mehr
Waffenlieferungen einen Frieden näher
bringen ich habe eher die Befürchtung
dass das zu einer Eskalation des
Konfliktes führen wird
Vorsitzender die man Bartsch sagt ohne
die Unterstützung aus dem Westen würde
die Ukraine keine Woche länger
existieren das ist so das hat er im
Dienstag im Sinne die Welt gesagt ohne
Waffen keine Ukraine irrt ihr Kollege
man muss ja sehen die Ukraine war ja
auch zu Beginn des Krieges bereits
Europas zweitstärkste Armee das heißt es
ist ja nicht so dass die Ukraine
unbewaffnet da gestanden hat und was wir
jetzt ja aber sehen ist natürlich der
Westen schickt jetzt Waffen Russland
rostet auch weiter auf die haben ja auch
in der eigene Waffenproduktion und haben
entsprechende Quellen auch von denen sie
Waffen beziehen das heißt jetzt haben
wir hier eine Art Wettkampf und dass die
Ukraine diesen
aufrüstungswettkampf gewinnen kann
gegenüber Russland das sehe ich wirklich
nicht das muss ich einfach sagen das
sehe ich nicht und das ist ja auch so
dass viele viele Militärexperten sagen
dieser Krieg wird auf dem Schlachtfeld
militärisch nicht gewonnen werden können
sondern das kann nur über Verhandlung
geschehen und aber nicht der Auffassung
man muss das möglichst schnell versuchen
mit der sterben Ende ihre Partei ist
darüber offensichtlich tief zerstritten
weil es diese beiden Lager gibt die
Parteivorsitzenden sehen das anders ihr
Kollege auch nun hat das Leben nicht
anders sie haben also anderen Gründen
jetzt
Demonstration nicht unterstützt weil sie
das dezentral eher organisieren wollten
aber programmatisch sind wir als LINKE
da sehr klar also wir sind dafür dass
Diplomatie vorne steht und das sagen
auch schon in Wissler und Martin Schöder
waren eine Deutlichkeit auch Dietmar
Bart sagt das da ging es weniger um
diejenigen die da noch mit demonstriert
haben an Samstag werden wir gleich
darüber diskutieren saskia esken ist bei
uns eine der beiden Parteivorsitzenden
der SPD Frau es gehen auch sie waren auf
einer Demonstration nämlich auf der am
Freitag
warum
tausende zehntausende hunderttausende
glaube ich überall in Deutschland
haben wir uns an dem Freitag im
Jahrestag dieses Überfalls Putins auf
die Ukraine an die Seite der Ukraine und
Ukraine gestellt haben unserer
solidaritätsausdruck verliehen und die
Aggression Russlands zurückgewiesen und
das ist das was ich tatsächlich auch bei
der Demonstration am Samstag vermisst
habe nämlich die klare Zurückweisung der
russischen Aggression
jetzt könnte man jetzt könnte man
natürlich sagen dass die Eskalation von
Waffenlieferungen vor der gewarnt wurde
durchaus auch etwas ist was ich in der
Arbeit von Olaf Scholz wiederfindet im
Grunde ist ja auch sein nachdenken und
sein den Dingen irgendwie auf den Grund
gehen die Verbündeten an die Seite holen
ein Vermeiden von Eskalation auch eine
Eskalation von Waffenlieferung hat er
gegebenenfalls der Demonstranten auch an
seiner Seite oder die Manifest
Unterzeichner also Olaf Schulz hat
zwei Tage nach dem Überfall Putins auf
die Ukraine am Samstagabend vor der
Zeiten wenn der Rede mit anderen
Partnern mit Franzosen und Briten und
Amerikanern gemeinsame Entscheidung
herbeigeführt dass Schulter gestützte
Panzerabwehr Waffen geliefert werden
sollen zwei Tage nach dem Überfall hat
Deutschland hat die deutsche Regierung
hat die deutsche Außenpolitik im übrigen
auch im großen Einvernehmen entschieden
wir unterstützen die Ukraine mit
Waffenlieferungen das war vom faktisch
vom ersten Tag an ganz klar und unsere
Erhaltung und das dort dann immer wieder
vom zögern gesprochen wird hat einfach
damit zu tun dass wir ganz klar gesagt
haben wir machen keine Alleingänge wir
stimmen uns immer ab mit den Verbündeten
insbesondere mit den US-Amerikanern aber
eben auch mit den anderen um um nicht in
den Einzelposition zu geraten sondern
wir wollen immer wieder deutlich machen
was
Putins größte Fehleinschätzung gewesen
ist nämlich dass die liberalen
Demokratien dieser Welt
auseinanderfallen werden angesichts
dieses Konflikts das ist nicht der Fall
das ist schon seine größte Niederlage
überhaupt diese Fehler Einschätzung wir
stehen zusammen und deswegen sind diese
Entscheidungen immer gemeinsam getroffen
worden und immer zur Zeit auch noch
nicht war man das Gefühl hatte dass es
sehr lange am Anfang erst um Helme ging
und dann später um die Waffen die der
Ukraine helfen soll
Frau Professor deitelhoff ist bei uns
Friedens und konfliktforscherin und sagt
uns was ist gut an diesem Manifest Frau
700.000 Menschen haben unterschrieben
was ist gut daran also ich glaube gut
daran ist dass es tatsächlich diese
Sehnsucht nach Frieden sehr deutlich
macht und das ist auch für eine
Irritation in der Debatte sorgt also
natürlich ist es einfach so dass wir
debattieren darüber wie wir effektiv die
Ukraine unterstützen können und
teilweise verengt sich das dann schnell
dass wir nur noch über Waffensysteme
reden welche sollen es sein wie genau
kann man das Organisieren und das ist
einfach sehr sehr gut dass tatsächlich
dieser friedensgedanke wieder deutlich
sozusagen uns ins Bewusstsein kommt und
dass wir irritiert werden und wieder
darüber nachdenken wir müssen ja beides
erreichen das finde ich gut daran
weniger gut finde ich daran oder oder
sage ich mal die problematische Seite
des Ganzen ist das natürlich sozusagen
wenig dabei gedacht wird wie kann man
denn die Bedingungen schaffen dass wir
zufrieden kommen also es wird eben eine
diplomatische Initiative oder sogar
Offensive gefordert finde ich alles
richtig aber was ist diese diplomatische
Offensive also wenn wir mit jemandem
verhandeln wollen dann brauchen wir ja
auch jemand der auf der anderen Seite
bereit ist zu tun den haben wir momentan
nicht wie kommen wir also dahin und das
ist sozusagen die Kernfrage und die wird
aber finde ich nicht hinreichend ernst
genommen weder von den Autoren hinter
diesem Manifest noch dann teilweise von
den Demonstrierenden wobei ich bei denen
immer sagen würde da sehe ich einfach
ganz viel Angst und die ist völlig
verständlich und ich sehe ganz viel
Wunsch nach Frieden und das ist auch
völlig verständlich und natürlich soll
das sozusagen auch geäußert werden
können Marina weißband ist bei uns aus
Münster zugeschaltet Deutsch Ukrainerin
gerade hat Annalena beerburg wieder
gesagt nur Waffenlieferungen verkürzen
das Leid der Menschen in der Ukraine
eine ganz banale Frage Marina weiß man
stimmt das so wenn der Krieg noch
wahnsinnig lange dauert
je nachdem wie die Waffenlieferungen
erfolgen also pauschal zu sagen nur
Waffenlieferungen stimmt glaube ich so
nicht das meinte sie wahrscheinlich auch
nicht ich denke wenn die
Waffenlieferungen so erfolgen dass man
immer so gerade genug hat um sich eines
russischen Sieges zu erwähnen aber nicht
genug um ernsthaft Gebiete zurück zu
erobern dann verlängern sie den Krieg
eher und das ist eine Perspektive die
ich auch bei deutschen
militärspezialisten dann ganz viel sehe
die sagen dieser Krieg wird noch Jahre
dauern ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht wie
und zwar nicht aufgrund der Waffen
sondern aufgrund der Menschen aufgrund
der Wirtschaft aufgrund der Familien die
gerade kein Einkommen haben die Leute
haben teilweise seit einem Jahr keinen
Job mehr das wie sollen die Familien
sich ernähren ich finde also beide
Positionen nicht gut ich finde die
Position nicht gut wir sollten Waffen
liefern aber langsam wir an einem Tropf
und andererseits die Positionen aber wir
sollten aufgeben und die Ukraine muss
jetzt Eingeständnisse machen und Land
abgeben
sondern aus meiner Licht ist das einzig
richtige erstens ich festzulegen was
will man das offen zu kommunizieren das
fehlt mir im Moment noch vom
Bundeskanzler und aus meiner Sicht wäre
die richtige Strategie die Ukraine früh
und so stark wie möglich zu unterstützen
damit Russland sich zurückziehen muss
und in dem Moment wo die russische Armee
zurückweicht selbst wenn Sie nicht bis
zur Grenze kommt wenn sie signifikant
zurückweicht dann werden russische
Kräfte und zufrieden mit Putin sein denn
historisch war das in Russland schon
immer so es gab genau einen Grund warum
Regierungen fallen und das sind
verlorene Kriege wenn Putin fällt durch
einen Putsch durch sonst was dann gibt
es eine ganz ganz neue verhandlungslage
und dann wird auch Russland noch mal
ganz anders reagieren können ich halte
das für das realistische Szenario aber
dazu müssten die russischen Truppen
nennenswert eben aus dem ukrainischen
Gebiet wieder raus wir werden gleich
darüber sprechen wie realistisch das ist
weil momentan sieht es auf dem
Schlachtfeld leider nicht so aus
Wolfgang Ischinger ist uns zugeschaltet
aus der schönen Stadt München
Botschafter war er lange und erfahren in
Washington und in London und
langjähriger Leute der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz einen guten Abend
nach München wir haben Wolfgang
Ischinger die Situation dass die Ukraine
ihrerseits nun sofort wieder Flugzeuge
fordern U-Boote fordern
Langstreckenraketen fordern Stichwort
Eskalation der Waffenlieferungen ist das
gut oder ist es einfach nicht nur nicht
besonders schlau oder ist es tatsächlich
auch gefährlich immer wieder neue es
sind ja auch streu- und Phosphor
Munition gefordert worden ist es schlau
oder einfach ungeschickt das jetzt in
einem solchen Zusammenhang weiter auf
dem Wunschzettel zu lassen sage ich mal
also darf ich mal einen kleinen Schritt
zurückgehen bevor ich auf diese Frage
kommt ich bin natürlich derjenige in
diesem Kreis der sich wirklich über
alles freut wenn hier nach Diplomatie
gerufen wird ich glaube alle
ich war ja großartig
habe ich mir seit Jahren gewünscht nur
die Frage die die Rufer nach Diplomatie
nicht beantworten können ist welche
Funktion soll denn zu welchem Zeitpunkt
die Diplomatie denn ausführt und ich
will mal äh wenn ich darf einfach zwei
Sätze als einer der selber mal an
Verhandlungen beteiligt war sind er
nicht viele der Lautsprecher die im
Augenblick in der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit darüber diskutieren
jemals in der Situation gewesen dass sie
mal tatsächlich
friedensverhandlung zu führen hatten ich
weiß wovon ich rede
Abkommen genau ja nicht nur nicht nur
ich habe auch ich habe auch den
Kosovo-Krise an den an den Verhandlungen
mitgewirkt und bei anderen Krisen also
es ist die erste Voraussetzung dafür
dass ernsthaft verhandelt wird
das in Moskau die Einsicht entstanden
ist oder zumindest entsteht das mit dem
weiteren Einsatz militärischer Mittel
Russland keine weiteren
territorialen oder sonstigen Vorteile
mehr erreichen kann
dieser Zustand ist dieser Zustand
erreicht der ist natürlich noch lange
nicht erreicht und deswegen würde ich in
dieser Situation ist mit Marina weißband
halten und sagen je mehr und je rasche
wir liefern können wir alle der Westen
desto größer werden die Chancen dass sie
Voraussetzungen für eine
Verhandlungslösung erreicht werden
können und ich halte es um uns auf die
Frage einzugehen halte es für völlig
normal und uns selbstverständlich dass
die Ukraine natürlich in diesem
Überlebenskampf nach allem was da geht
fliegt schießt ruft was wir liefern wir
der Westen liefern können das muss das
wird ja auch sorgfältigst abgewogen und
da erfahrener Führung ich sehe durch die
USA und wir beteiligen uns daran in dem
Maße indem wir uns daran beteiligen
können und wollen was Flugzeuge angeht
haben wir nach allem was ich weiß
ohnehin nichts zu bieten also stellt
sich diese Frage für uns im Augenblick
konkret wie auch die Bundesregierung ja
wiederholt gesagt hat gar nicht aber wer
den Krieg beendet wer den Krieg beenden
will und zwar wer verhindern will dass
das ein langer wie vorhin gesagt in
langer kriegte wird der sie über Jahre
hinzieht der muss jetzt mehr liefern
also
klotzen nicht kleckern nicht weiter
trödeln Deutschland hat wie einige der
Partner auch in dem Jahr 22 da will ich
Frau SGB sprechen natürlich ziemlich
getreudet auch nach dem Bild dass wir
international abgegeben haben wir dürfen
nicht weiter trödeln wir müssen jetzt
gemeinsam mit den Partnern klotzen damit
dieser Krieg möglichst rasch und die
hier sind paar Jahren und dann noch
gewaltigerem leiden auf beiden Seiten
der Front beendet werden kann
wir haben immer das Problem dass wenn
Gäste nicht bei uns am Tisch sitzen
können sondern geschaltet werden aus der
Ferne wir natürlich schwerer deutlich
machen können dass die Diskussion eben
eine ist die wir noch mal führen wollen
zum Sinn oder Unsinn jetzt um diese
Diplomatie zu ersuchen Frau Mohammed Ali
sagt sie haben das so formuliert Frau
alides ist im Grunde ist der Kanzler
seinen Amtsarzt verletzt wenn er sich
für Kampfpanzer ausgesprochen hat
aber also wenn ich da kann ich direkt da
anknüpfen was äh der China gesagt hat
ich halte das für ein hochgefährlichen
Kurs und das führt mich auch zu dem was
da in dem Manifest ähm drin steht denn
die Gefahr die ja besteht und das ist ja
auch der Grund warum der Kanzler da
gezögert hat auch mit den Kampfpanzern
ist eben dass man an einem Punkt kommt
wo man als Beteiligter als Kriegspartei
gesehen wird und das ist natürlich eine
große Gefahr die man vermeiden muss denn
wenn dieser Krieg sich ausweitet wenn
sozusagen ein NATO Land in diesen Krieg
jetzt eingreift und das kann aber im
gewissen Zeitpunkt auch geschehen wenn
es zum Beispiel auch Soldaten
ausgebildet werden an diese Waffen und
so weiter dass das dann völkerrechtlich
als Eingriff gewählt hat Teilnahme
gewesen
ich glaube nicht dass wir zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt Kriegspartei sind aber wir
drohen Kriegspartei zu werden oder als
große von Russland als solche angesehen
zu werden das heißt es ist ein
hochgefährlicher Kurs und wenn man jetzt
der Logik von den Ischinger erfolgt dann
müsste man eigentlich sagen na gut dann
muss die Nacht oder jetzt rein dann muss
der muss die Nase da jetzt Truppen
schicken und Russland rauskommen aber
das geschieht ja mit Absicht nicht weil
Russland nur mal eine Atom macht ist und
dann muss man eine andere Methode
anstrengen weil die Gefahr dass dieser
kriegt sich ausweitet ist vorhanden und
die muss man unbedingt bauen
das lade mir Putin im Völkerrecht
nachschlägt um dann beurteilen zu können
ist dass wir doch unbedingt vermeiden
müssen dass dieser schreckliche Krieg
sich weiter ausweitet ich meine auch
hier bei uns in Deutschland haben viele
Menschen
dass dieser Krieg eskaliert
ist genau deswegen
genau aber genau deswegen muss man doch
auch bei der Frage wie man es
militärisch unterstützt da ich sag mal
eine große Sorgfalt weil walten lassen
wenn man den Kurs sondern eschinger
einfach folgt und sagt jetzt bitte so
vieles irgendwie geht das halte ich für
gefährlich und Verantwortung
nicht gemacht sondern es wird ja
tatsächlich auch immer sehr klar
abgewogen aber wenn wir eben sagen wir
haben es mit einer nuklearen Macht zu
tun und deswegen müssen wir nach anderen
Methoden suchen was sind die anderen
Methoden wir haben es mit einem
Aggressor zu tun und wir beobachten das
jetzt seit 15 20 Jahren und den werden
wir eben nicht sozusagen mit
freundlichen Angeboten stocken können
sondern wir müssen ihn militäre stoppen
daran glaube ich weiß die Maus keinen
Faden ab die Frage ist wie uns das
gelingt so dass wir einerseits
verhindern dass Russland seine Ziele
umsetzen kann und andererseits nicht in
diese nukleare Konfrontation kommen es
ist letzten Endes so politisch
betrachtet politisch gesehen kann Putin
zu jeder Zeit sagen sagen dass wir eine
Kriegspartei sind darauf haben wir auch
überhaupt keinen Einfluss aber deswegen
machen wir Entscheidungen so und jetzt
mache ich schon so ein wir dabei also
deswegen glaube ich macht die derzeitige
Regierung ihre Entscheidung für
Waffenlieferung so dass bei jeder
Entscheidung abgewogen wird und auch
danach geprüft wird was passiert denn
was macht denn Russland wie verhält sich
Russland denn im Krieg fällt bevor man
dann weitere Entscheidung trifft also
das was sie einfordern ich finde das
absolut richtig eine Risikoabschätzung
muss immer dabei sein genau das passiert
aber nur es kann nicht dazu führen dass
wir gar nichts mehr tun ansonsten wird
Russland sich durchsetzen die Ukraine
wird aufhören zu existieren und unser
aller Sicherheit in Europa ist noch
massiver gefährdet und das ist einfach
sozusagen
Corporation sagt dieser Krieg wird auf
dem Schlachtfeld nicht gewonnen werden
können es wird nicht gelingen Russland
militärisch zu besiegen wir erklären Sie
sich das denn aber ich weiß nicht
was ist eigentlich ein militärischer
Sieg wir tun dann manchmal so sozialen
militärischer Sieg die bedingungslose
Kapitulation erwartet die irgendwie
jemand nein ich nicht wird man ja schon
nein absolut nicht das ist totaler Unfug
das wird immer sozusagen in den Raum
gestellt um dann sozusagen alle
Strategien die auf einen Sieg ziehen zu
désuieren aber tatsächlich fordert das
niemanden
nicht verlieren
genau
mit Russland erst verhandelt werden wenn
der letzte Soldaten
das stimmt die sich auch bei Twitter
oder so kommt sowas aber ich sehe sie
nicht bei ernsthaften Vertreterin und
Vertretern
aber das ist doch normal also wir reden
über Verhandlungen unter Feinden bei
Verhandlung und der Feinden wird man
nicht bevor man überhaupt mal
Verhandlungstisch ist schon alles
hinlegen und sagen eigentlich könnte man
auch vorstellen dass ich euch den Don
was her gebe oder sonst was sondern was
man machen das hier ist meine maximal
Position
gesprochen
muss man immer besonders
freundlich sein weil sie schon längst
den Finger gehoben hat Marina weiß man
ich würde sehr sehr gerne auf Frau mal
mit Dali eingehen und auf das Argument
der Eskalation weil ich glaube das
Teilen viele Menschen in Deutschland und
auch diese Angst wie weit eskaliert das
eigentlich
noch mal ich gehöre auch nicht zu denen
die sagen und ich glaube auch nicht
selenski die sagen die können erst reden
wenn der letzte russische Soldat raus
ist sondern ich glaube es muss eine
klare Bewegung geben die Pudding zeigt
dass er auf dem Schlachtfeld nichts mehr
gewinnen kann und ich kann mir auch gut
vorstellen dass silenski sogar gegen den
Willen Fehler Ukraine geht und Gespräche
sucht wenn viele Ukraine das noch nicht
unterstützen würden weil sie sagen die
Integrität unseres vollständigen Landes
inklusive der Krim muss gewährleistet
sein dass er sich an der Stelle
politisch
Opfer kann ich mir gut vorstellen es
realistischen Ausgang aber ich möchte
auf die Eskalation eingehen wie wir
angeblich riskieren wenn wir auf diesen
Punkt zu arbeiten
man kann sich das sehr einfach verdienen
wertigen nehmen wir an einen Räuber
überfällt ein Menschen aufhelligter
Straße klaut die Handtasche und
verprügelt ihn und dann kommt die
Polizei und sagt bitte hör jetzt auf
diesen Menschen zu verprügeln dann
kriegst du auch die Hälfte des Inhalts
deiner Handtasche und dann kannst Du
gesichtswarend gehen
wie wahrscheinlich werden daraufhin
zukünftige Raubüberfälle und wie
wahrscheinlich werden sie wenn die
Polizei mit Gewalt den Räuber davon
abhält in diesem Fall wirkt Gewalt
tatsächlich weitere Gewalt vorbeugend
insofern finde ich einfach von der
samstagsdemo jetzt diese
friedensvorstellungen naiv die sagt
Frieden ist die jetzige Abwesenheit
akuter Kampfhandlungen das ignoriert
erstens die Realität in den besetzten
Gebieten wo immer noch Menschen getötet
vergewaltigt gefoltert werden wo Kinder
aus der Ukraine nach Russland entführt
werden und zweitens ignoriert es eben
auch die Realität der völlig logischen
zwangsläufigen Folgerung ja das
aggressionskriege das Angriffskriege
sich lohnen und damit natürlich auch
wahrscheinlicher werden wir hatten
letzte Woche den Bundeskanzler bei uns
in der Sendung und er hat tatsächlich
auch bestätigt was sie sagten nämlich
eine große Sorge
wie groß ist ihre Sorge dass wir in
einem Jahr hier wieder sitzen könnten
und dieser Krieg immer noch nicht zu
Ende ist
ganz offen das ist eine meiner größten
Sorgen dass das jetzt ein sehr lange
sich hinziehender Krieg wird mit
unglaublichen Zerstörung und Verlusten
so Frau esken offensichtlich wünscht
sich auch Olaf Scholz dass das erstens
nicht nur ein sehr langer Krieg mit
großem Verlusten und Zerstörungen wird
sondern das ist einer werden muss der
möglichst schnell zu beenden ist wie
erreicht man dieses ein möglichst
schnelles Ende dieses furchtbaren
Krieges ich will noch mal auf die
Demonstration am 24 auf die vielen
Demonstrationen am 24 ähm hinweisen und
deutlich machen auch dort haben 10.000
100.000 Menschen für den Frieden
demonstriert denn niemand wünscht sich
keinen Frieden
ich glaube die vielen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine hier in Deutschland die ja dort
auch mit demonstriert haben wünschen
sich nicht sehnlicher als Frieden und
zwar sobald wie möglich denn ein
baldiger Frieden bedeutet weniger Tote
weniger weniger Verletzte weniger
gefolter dem
vergewaltigte verschleppte Menschen
deswegen ganz klar ist ein Frie nicht so
schnell wie möglich anzustreben aber was
ist denn ein nachhaltiger Frieden wie
kann denn ein Frieden tatsächlich auch
nicht nur die Abwesenheit von
Kampfhandlungen bedeuten sondern dass
ein Land auch wirklich wieder zufrieden
kommen kann und dazu ist ja die
Souveränität und die Integrität der
Ukraine zu gewährleisten und die ist ja
nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld zu erreichen
die ist nur in Verhandlungen zu
erreichen und zu diesen Verhandlungen
ich muss es ganz deutlich sagen ist
Putin nicht bereit auf dem Kunden aber
jetzt drüber gesprochen wurde jetzt muss
endlich die Diplomatie sprechen oder
schuld war wenige Tage vor dem Überfall
Putins in Moskau und hat mit an dem
langen Tisch richtig an dem langen Tisch
an dem auch andere schon mit ihm
gesprochen haben hat mit Pudding
gesprochen und er telefoniert ja auch
sagt er regelmäßig mit Putin Sohn tut es
Präsident macron und Präsident beiden
und ist es ist keine Bereitschaft zu
erkennen in diesen Gesprächen dass das
Putin anerkennt dass er erstens es nicht
erreichen wird den die die die
Demokratie in der Welt zu spalten und
das ist nicht erreichen wird die
Kampfbereitschaft und die
Abwehrbereitschaft der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine zu brechen aber sind wir
Kriegspartei ist nach wie vor eine Frage
und offensichtlich ist das auch bei der
Außenministerin und dem
Verteidigungsminister ein bisschen
unsicherer in der Beantwortung schauen
Sie mal hier
against wir führen einen Krieg gegen
Russland
in Zeiten in denen man als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland an einem
Krieg beteiligt ist indirekt
der Satz geht natürlich noch weiter
waren das mehr als Versprecher Frau
esken na ich sehe eine gewisse Neigung
auch in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit
immer nach Unterschieden und nach feinen
zisilierungen zu suchen die dort
einen Zwist aufmachen der aber nicht
vorhanden ist wir sind uns alle drüber
einig wir wollen nicht Kriegspartei sein
weder als Deutschland noch als NATO und
wir stehen weiterhin unverbrüchlich an
der Seite der Ukraine weil die Ukraine
in dem in dem Konflikt in dem
sogenannten Konflikte einfach einen
Angriffskrieg ist auf der Seite der
Überfallenen steht und auf der anderen
Seite steht der Aggressor und diese
Aggression haben wir zurückzuweisen die
müssen wir deshalb zurückweisen wie Frau
weiß man das gerade eben erklärt hat
weil ansonsten diese Aggressionen nach
also dann sind wir bei einem bei einer
Tatsache die wir alle aus den Medien
entnehmen konnten oder besser gesagt
einem Bericht das Wort Street journey
Olaf Scholz und Emanuel macron sollen
versucht haben
Aufnahme von Friedensgesprächen
zu überzeugen und zwar später in diesem
Jahr und so fassen die Journalisten
Kollegen das zusammen
Kriegsmüdigkeit oder Realpolitik
so lange wie nötig ist der Slogan für
die Unterstützung Kiews doch laut Wall
Street journey gibt es in London Paris
und Berlin erste Anzeichen für ein
Ablaufdatum
Anfang Februar sollen es macron und
Scholz selensky signalisiert haben
ein Zeitfenster für Rückeroberungen bis
Herbst
dann seit Zeit für Verhandlungen mit
Moskau
in dieser Woche Fragezeichen
des Bundeskanzlers Deutschlands und des
französischen Präsidenten
ich weiß nicht wie viel an diesem
Bericht dran ist wenn er wahr ist dann
wäre das natürlich ein fatales Zeichen
denn das ist ja geradezu eine Einladung
an putinen nicht zu verhandeln weil
warum würde er verhandeln wollen wenn er
weiß er muss jetzt nur bis Herbst
durchhalten und danach hört der besten
auf die Ukraine zu unterstützen das ist
ja praktisch eine Garantie so und dann
sind wir bei der Frage Frau deitelhoff
warum so etwas in die Öffentlichkeit
kommt und für wie profund Sie diese
Nachricht halten also ich glaube die
Frage ist eher was ist für ein Ziel
hatte es finden die ganze Zeit Gespräche
sowohl mit der russischen Führung statt
als auch mit der ukrainischen Seite um
eben auch auszuloten ist
Verhandlungsbereitschaft da in welchen
Bereichen ist sie da wie könnte man
Weiterkommen das ist jetzt hier im
Februar bei einem ja auch persönlichen
Treffen also Lenski ist ja sozusagen
nach Westeuropa gereist das ist da noch
mal auch ein Versuch gehabt zu gucken
wenn wir dir zum Beispiel eben darum
ging es wenn ich es richtig sehe bei
diesem Gespräch eigentlich wenn wir dir
bestimmte Sicherheit Garantien
organisieren können bist du dann bereit
auch wenn vielleicht nicht die
Maximalziele erfüllt sind an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren ich
glaube das ist es was man hier
eigentlich so ein bisschen ausloten
wollte
da hat also Sicherheitsgarantien und
welcher Art die eigentlich sein müssten
aber es ging nicht darum ihm unbedingt
ein Verfallsdatum jetzt mitzugeben
sondern eher anzudeuten darüber haben
wir auch schon gesprochen wir wollen
alle keinen langen Krieg niemand will
das das will auch die ukrainische Seite
nicht sondern man will diesen Krieg
natürlich rasch beenden und zu schauen
und der welchen Konstellation könnte man
denn beide Parteien anfangen aber noch
mal Blick auf die ausgerechnet die
deutsche Regierung wenn Herr Pistorius
Frau eskim sagt die Ukraine soll diesen
Krieg gewinnen und der Bundeskanzler bis
heute diese Formulierung vermeidet
sondern sagt Russland darf den Krieg
nicht verlieren ist das genau dieses
spielen mit dem Super oder unterscheidet
sich da der Wunsch von der Realität also
allen die sich egal mit welcher Nase an
der Stelle auch ausdrücken bringen zum
Ausdruck dass wir die die russische
Aggression klar zurückweisen müssen
diese Völkerrechts wegen diesen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
müssen wir klar zurückweisen eben um
auch deutlich zu machen das Völkerrecht
Bild Angriffskriege sind zu echten und
wir sind nicht nicht bereit dazu die
Folgen eines solchen Angriffskrieges
hinzunehmen und die Unterwerfung der
Ukraine hinzunehmen das ist die die
Antwort die in all diesen Formulierungen
muss den Kampf gewinnen sie haben einen
sehr sehr langes Gespräch mit dem
Bundeskanzler geführt haben wollen
absolut haben sie eine Erklärung dafür
warum er das ausspringen möchte er sich
eine Tür offen lassen ist ja das was man
sofort vermutet weil ich möchte einfach
ich habe es vorher schon gesagt dieses
Suche nach nach kleinen Unterschied und
die sind so klein und und ob man ob man
da unter Umständen einen Unterschied
herausfinden kann und das dann versuchen
zu interpretieren finde ich sehr
anstrengend ich finde es ganz klar hat
man auch heute in der
Regierungserklärung wieder hören können
und auch in den ähm vielen Reden der
koalitionsabgeordneten die da noch
gesprochen haben ganz klar wir stehen an
der Seite unverbrüchlich an der Seite
der Ukraine und weisen die russische
Aggression zurück das was wir gerade
gehört und vorgelesen haben und gezeigt
haben sprechen dagegen Frau eskim es ist
die Frage an den erfahrenen Diplomaten
der Ischinger sagen sie so etwas gehört
zum rechten Zeitpunkt einfach dazu oder
glauben Sie dass es wirklich dramatisch
ist wenn es Belege dafür gibt dass
ausgerechnet diese beiden
regierungs-ski davon überzeugen möchten
er im Herbst mit Verhandlungen zu Beginn
also ich halte es für vollkommen normal
es wäre es wäre abnormal wenn es anders
wäre dass natürlich mit dem mit dem Chef
der ukrainischen Seite mit präsidensky
nachgedacht wird wie könnten
vorausgesetzt die militärische
Entwicklung erlaubt das wie könnten im
Laufe hoffentlich ihr früher als später
die Voraussetzungen für
Verhandlungen für einen Waffen steht für
etc aussehen das ist doch dass das
Handwerkszeug ich bin nicht so sicher ob
ich glücklich bin darüber dass dieser
Bericht des Wall Street Journal
überhaupt das Licht der Öffentlichkeit
erreicht hat wissen Sie wissen Sie ich
will mal als praktizierende Diplomat
folgendes sagen es gibt in der
Diplomatie genau zwei Formen erstens die
öffentliche Diplomatie das ist das was
wir hier erleben das hat häufig wichtige
Gründe das hat aber häufig aber auch
Risiken und Nebenwirkungen die wir ja
gerade hier diskutieren es gibt daneben
die sogenannte stille oder
Geheimdiplomatie und ich möchte hier mal
ein wirklich aus der Tiefe meines
Herzens und meiner jetzt über
40-jährigen Berufserfahrung mal sagen
Kinder denkt mal daran dass in einer
Kriegs in einer Konfliktsituation wenn
so Krisen Diplomatie geht ein großer
Vorteil in der stillen Diplomatie liegt
nicht jedes Gespräch muss gleich an die
große Glocke gehängt werden
Entschuldigung wir sagen die ganze Zeit
können wir auch die Marina weiß man
gleich noch mal fragen dass die Ukraine
ihr Schicksal selbst entscheiden wird
das ist der Text der westlichen
Regierungschefs das ist bei der Ukraine
liegt darüber zu entscheiden ist das
dann nicht gelogen
wir sie nicht nur auf der einen Seite
unterstützen nach
Maßgabe der begreifungskraft der Ukraine
aber nicht genug unterstützen und dann
auch noch versuchen Sie egal auf welchem
Weg davon zu überzeugen dass zu einem
Friedensschluss eben einen Zugeständnis
gehören wird und wir an ihren sieht
nicht glauben
ich finde das eine wirklich ganz
wichtige Frage und ich will dazu
folgendes sagen natürlich ist das
Prinzip richtig und zwangsläufig auch
notwendig dass es die Entscheidung der
ukrainischen Führung ist wann und wie
sie mit wem wie verhandeln will das
entbindet uns
im Westen die USA die europäischen
Partner die Bundesregierung aber nicht
von der Verpflichtung dass uns mögliche
ein gutem Rat an Leitlinien zu
entwickeln und ich will jetzt mal hier
folgendes sagen wissen Sie wir geben uns
natürlich gegenüber der Vertreterin der
Linken und der Leute die sie
unterstützen nicht wahr hier leider eine
böse weil wir im weil wir natürlich
sagen ja im Augenblick ist kein Raum für
Diplomatie und so weiter ich plädiere
dafür dass wir das machen was ich als
damaliger Staatssekretär mit Joschka
Fischer im April 1999 schon mal gemacht
habe da haben wir nämlich kurz nach
Ausbruch des Kosovo Kriegs einen
innerhalb von drei Tagen das Gerippe
eines friedenswickel und ich bin der
Meinung es ist jetzt richtig wenn wir
uns mit den Partnern
das ist zunächst mal ganz kleiner Kreis
von gleich Großbritannien USA und uns
und vielleicht ein paar anderen wenigen
Partnern wenn wir uns mit denen nicht
nur in Ramstein über die militärischen
Notwendigkeiten abstimmen sondern wenn
wir uns und dann natürlich gemeinsam mit
der Ukraine mit der Frage befassen wie
genau könnten denn die
Sicherheitsgarantien aussehen was wäre
notwendige
Überwachungsmechanismen falls es in
welcher Form auch immer und an welchem
territorialen Ende der ukrainischen
Grenze es zu einer Waffen würde wie wird
der überwacht brauchen wir die ohne
brauchen wir die CD wir kümmert sich
darum brauchen wir eine Diesing geht mit
Zone es gibt tausend Fragen die müssen
alle
die müssen alle im Detail vorbereitet
werden und zwar nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit sondern hinter
verschlossenen Tür
dass wir gemeinsam handlungsfähig sind
wenn es dann mal tatsächlich zu
verhandlungsmöglich Fähigkeiten kommen
könnte wir haben die Ukraine zu beraten
und ihr zu helfen die hoffentlich
richtige Entscheidung zu treffen die die
schlussendliche Entscheidung muss sie
selbst verantworten so und dann stelle
ich trotzdem die Frage zu Marina
weißband wenn es immer heißt Frau
weißband dass die Ukraine ihr Schicksal
selbst entscheiden wird glauben sie dass
den Menschen die ihnen das unentwegt
sagen glauben die Ukraine das
das wäre höchst gerade naiv die Ukraine
hat das im Budapester
Sicherheitsgarantien gegeben wurden
unter anderem von Russland sie hat dafür
Atomwaffen aufgegeben der Rest ist
Geschichte
also die Seite dieser ganze
konfliktieren entstanden ja hätte die
Ukraine damals nicht so gehandelt dann
haben wir auch schon gesehen was
passiert wenn europäische Länder für die
Ukraine einen Friedensplan entwerfen da
ist mindestens zwei bei rausgekommen
jeder der das in der Ukraine damals
beobachtet hat hat gesagt das ist ein
umsetzbarer Vertrag das ist
gar nicht möglich umzusetzen weil da
drin ganz ganz kritische Punkte gar
nicht geklärt waren und so ist es ja
auch gekommen und er hat eben zu einer
neuerlichen Invasion geführt deshalb ich
bin immer skeptisch weil ich sehr das
Gefühl habe dass in den Köpfen der Leute
die das entscheiden und das sind ja auch
oft ältere Leute die noch im Kalten
Krieg aufgewachsen sind dass da die
Ukraine nicht so richtig einen Platz
einnimmt also souveräner eigenständiger
Staat und in der Politik wissen wir ja
auch dass die Interessen von kleineren
Staaten jetzt nicht unbedingt die
Schlüsselrolle spielen ich bin naiv
genug anzunehmen dass so ein
Friedensplan jetzt natürlich jetzt schon
lange hinter verschlossenen Türen aber
ich finde es unehrlich von einem
Bundeskanzler Scholz wenn er wirklich
Druck macht und sagt wir wollen jetzt
schnell Friedensverhandlungen und wir
sprechen mit silenski darüber das wäre
ehrlich das wäre super von ihm wenn er
dann aber auch im April vergangenen
Jahres gesagt hätte wir werden auch
Kampfpanzer liefern und wir werden jetzt
damit anfangen die Soldaten auszubilden
weil wir sehen ja dass das eine Weile
dauert und wir geben Russland nicht Zeit
zu mobilisieren und diese mobilisierten
Männer auszubilden und in die Ukraine zu
schicken also entweder man man man
liefert langsam und dann lässt man sich
auch Zeit oder man macht Druck für
friedensverhandlung aber dann schafft
man auch die entsprechende Hilfe oder
man will das Ukraine direkt noch mal
ganz deutlich ist es handelt sich um
Spekulation niemand macht Luftdruck in
Bezug auf Friedensverhandlungen aber wie
hier Ischinger völlig richtig sagt wenn
niemand muss uns sagen dass Diplomatie
stattfinden muss die findet statt aber
die findet selbstverständlich nicht in
der öffentlichen gibt es immer in
solchen Situationen im Krieg erst recht
und wahrscheinlich auch Lügen
definitiv auch Lügen nicht nur
wahrscheinlich
der ehemalige israelische
Ministerpräsident das ist genauso
wichtig hier zu erwähnen weil es auch
ganz häufig thematisiert wird und unter
anderem auch von Sarah Wagenknecht als
ein
Fakt erzählt wird dass es im Lichte des
letzten Jahres im April eine
friedenssituation gegeben hat um die
Verhandlungen ähm moderiert von Erdogan
und das die Ukraine bereits dazu war die
Krim herzugeben und auf eine NATO
Mitgliedschaft zu verzichten ganz kurz
erzählt und dass die Russen bereit
gewesen wären zu einem Friedensschluss
und die die
verhindert haben oder gestoppt haben so
geht die unterschiedliche Übersetzung
das ist zu diesem 50% möglichen Frieden
kommt waren die Briten und die
Amerikaner was ist dran an dieser
Erzählung hat Herr Bennett das alles
erfunden nein ich glaube nicht dass er
das alles erfunden hat aber da fehlt
sozusagen ganz viel an dieser Geschichte
das erste was man sagen muss es ist eher
märz als im April im April war die Sache
nämlich eigentlich schon gelaufen und
was im März passiert ist dass die
Ukraine tatsächlicher einen einen Plan
auf den Tisch gelegt hat dass Istanbuler
Community da ging es unter anderem darum
dass man bereit war Neutralität fest zu
schreiben nach einem nationalen
Referendum dass man bereit für den
Status der Krämpfe 15 Jahre sozusagen
offen zu halten man war nicht bereit
ehrlich gesagt über den dornbas zu
sprechen in dieser Hinsicht aber und das
alles sollte im Gegenzug von Sicherheit
Garantien passieren die russische Seite
wollte nichts von diesen
Sicherheitsgarantien hören wenn dann
wollte sie selber dabei sein und die
sollten relativ schwach sein und die
territorialen Fragen also die warum wir
auch sehen dass es geht die waren nicht
geklärt die waren praktisch immer noch
strittig in dieser Situation haben
damals dritten und die Amerikaner gesagt
wir messen Putin eher in dem was er tut
und nicht so sehr an dem was er sagt die
waren recht skeptisch und die russische
Seite sagt es tut mir leid aber ich muss
es einmal erklären die russische Seite
sagte dann am 29.3 in dieser
Verhandlungssituation wollen wir
Vertrauen schaffen und als Zeichen des
guten Willens ziehen wir die Truppen aus
der Region Kiew zurück und beenden
sozusagen die Kampfhandlungen in der
Region Kiew und das Ergebnis war was
steckte dahinter sie haben ihre Truppen
umgruppiert und haben die Offensive in
dornbas begonnen sie haben weiterhin
sozusagen mit systematischen
Bombardierung weitergemacht und kurze
Zeit später ist Mucha entdeckt worden
ihre PIN und all die anderen geheiltaten
und zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren diese
Verhandlung gescheitert und das heißt es
war nicht die USA Großbritannien die
hier etwas blockiert haben oder etwas
beendet haben es war die russische
Kriegsführung und die russische
Verhandlungsführung die sozusagen
jegliches Vertrauen und weitere
Verhandlung gestoppt hat und zu dem
Zeitpunkt waren keine verhand möglich so
damit ist der Ball wieder bei Frau
mit Ali danke für diesen historischen
Auszug wir verstehen dass eben
offensichtlich auch das
Erinnerungsvermögen selbst eines
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten er hat
das
hinterher gerade gerückt oder besser
gesagt hat gesagt er erinnert sich nicht
mehr genau und dann kam Butcher und dann
war sowieso alles ganz anders
die Sarah Wagenknecht benutzt und nimmt
gerne diese Geschichte das ist jetzt die
etwas lange Brücke aber es wird diese
Geschichte gerne genommen um zu sagen
die eigentlichen Gewinner dieser ganzen
Situation werden die US-Amerikaner sein
und eigentlich geht's nur darum den
US-amerikanischen Einfluss in Europa
wieder zu vergrößen und NATO zu
erweitern schließen sie sich auch da
Sahra Wagenknecht an glauben Sie dass
die USA unser eigentliches Problem ist
wissen Sie ich glaube wer im Moment ans
eindeutig von diesem an diesem Krieg
Gewinne macht und davon profitiert es
erstmal die Rüstungsindustrie und ich
glaube wer hier gerade sehr leidet das
sind die Menschen der Ukraine so das
vorausgesetzt selbstverständlich gibt es
auch in diesem Krieg Interessen die über
das hinausgehen was ist Russland an der
Ruine hat sondern es geht insgesamt um
Geo strategische und geopolitische
Interessen dass die USA und das hat ja
auch die Randgruppe Reschen in ihrer
Ausarbeitung gesagt ein Interesse daran
hat diesen Krieg möglichst lange
hinzuziehen das glaube ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht ähm denn das ist für mich
nicht belegbar aber das natürlich da
geopolitische Dinge eine Rolle spielen
dass die Rolle von China eine Rolle
spielt das ist darum wirtschaftliche
Vormachtstellung in der Welt geht dass
das alles Dinge sind die relevant sind
auch in diesem Krieg das kann man ja nun
nicht ernsthaft abstreiten und das muss
man ja auch in der ganzen Situation mit
berücksichtigen und meinen Ansatz wäre
es nicht zu sagen die USA sind in diesem
Krieg jetzt Schuld also das ist ja auch
erkennbar nicht der Fall Schul
einmarschiert ist in die Ukraine auch
wenn jeder Krieger eine Vorgeschichte
hat trotzdem ist das ist ja der schuld
daran ist aber was ich wirklich vermisse
und das komme ich auf das was ich Dinger
gesagt hat ist eine erkennbare
diplomatische Offensive ich würde nicht
würde nicht sagen was er gesagt hat dass
man da jetzt nur ich sag mal auf
westlicher Seite verhandeln muss ich
glaube man muss das internationaler
aufstellen ich glaube dass der die
Vorstöße von Präsident Dula aus
Brasilien gut sind dass er sagt wir
brauchen eine internationale
friedensoffensive mit der man eben auch
Länder wie Brasilien wie China mit
einbindet und Druck auf Russland zu
erhöhen und besonders auch die Länder
mit den Russland droht sich sonst auch
wirtschaftlich unabhängig zu machen vom
Westen das muss man ja auch sehen wir
haben die Sanktionen die sonst durch die
gegenüber Russland die nur auf meiner
Sicht und nachdem was ich was ich
darüber weiß mäßigen Erfolg hat was auch
damit zusammenhängt dass Russland sich
immer wirtschaftlich immer weniger
abhängig macht von dem Westen und das
ist natürlich ein Problem das heißt ich
muss versuchen auf internationaler Ebene
hier den Druck
deutlich zu erhöhen wir bleiben müsste
man tun wir bleiben wir kommen auf jeden
Fall noch zu den potentiellen
Vermittlern ähm Marina weiß man die
Frage ist entscheidend welche Position
welche Rolle spielt ausgerechnet dieser
US-amerikanische Präsident das werden
sie und das müssen sie anders sehen als
die Linke in Deutschland ist
ausgerechnet so beiden aus Sicht der
Ukraine ein Garant für die Hilfe des
Westens
sagen wir er ist im Moment leider die
größte Hoffnung so möchte ich das
formulieren weil ich kann seine Rolle
nicht genau einschätzen ich beobachte
dass er einerseits natürlich eine
riesige Hilfestellung ist also rein
materiell können die USA einfach viel
viel mehr stemmen als dasselbe Estland
dass der stärkste Unterstützer der
Ukraine pro Kopf ist aber natürlich
verfügen die Amerikaner über ganz
anderen Mittel und sie setzen diese
Mittel auch ein auch hier nicht immer
ohne Zögern auch da wurden gerade im
Frühling ein paar wirklich unnötige
Runden durch den Senat gedreht
aber das tun sie die Rede von beiden
dass er überhaupt die Ukraine besucht
hat dass er dort geredet hat das hat
Ukraine unfassbar viel Hoffnung gemacht
wie sehr die USA einen Interesse daran
haben dass dieser Krieg lange dauert
kann ich nicht abschätzen aber es ist
natürlich ein Gedanke der mich gestreift
hat und es ist vor allem ein Gedanke der
mich dann gestreift hat als beiden
gesagt hat ich bin bereit aus der
Ukraine ein zweites Afghanistan zu
machen
was nun wirklich niemand will und
deswegen es fällt mir schwer zu
beurteilen ich halte es für
problematisch dass wir als Europa auch
militärisch so von den Staaten abhängig
sind ganz einfach weil selbst wenn
beiden wirklichen gerannt ist was ist
wenn Trump wieder gewinnt
völlig aufgeschmissen wir wollen gerade
noch mal nachfragen Frau deitelhoff
dieses Zitat von Joe beiden aus der
Ukraine ein zweites Afghanistan zu
machen ist das in ihren Augen auch an
eine mögliche Lösung ich glaube es geht
hier tatsächlich um eine zweite Ebene
der konfliktführung die wir auch häufig
nicht so ernst nehmen aber die genauso
wichtig ist und dass diese
psychologische Ebene und man versucht
sich ja eigentlich wechselseitig
insofern abzuschrecken dass man zeigen
will man hat den längeren Atem also
whatever it takes du kommst hier nicht
weiter und umgekehrt Putin macht genau
das gleiche indem man eben sagt was
immer der Westen macht ich werde es auf
alle Fälle noch weiter treiben können
aber das ist sozusagen eine Ebene eben
der psychologischen Kriegsführung die
wir medialer mitbekommen als glaube ich
jemals in einem Krieg zuvor und das ist
auch ein Problem mit Blick auf die
Geheimhaltung die ja auch herrischinger
schon noch mal angemahnt hat ne aber das
müssen wir einfach sehen das sind
Signale die man sich wechselseitig
sendet und durch um um um anzudeuten
oder ganz deutlich zu machen dass man
länger durchhalten kann als die andere
Seite und dass die andere Seite deswegen
doch jetzt endlich mal umdenken soll